Okay,
we're live. Hello.
Little late today.
Yesterday was kind of a drag, honestly.
C++ um Torch API is just such a pain in
the ass.
I'm going to try to pick up um some
tempo again today
and
probably work on some experimental side
stuff. Maybe work on constellation. Just
try not to drive myself crazy with that
and uh see if I can hammer out some good
progress on the next update.
Speaking of which,
this
open chat.
There we are.
Cool. So,
yeah, what we're going to do here
is we're going to start figuring out
some basic experiments
because I believe we still have we still
have the Python version, right?
See,
see if we can go recover
original performance.
Okay. Yeah. So, something is just
totally messed up, I suppose, because
policy num layers needs to be this.
Yeah. Let's go figure out what I was uh
even doing with our old parameters.
There.
So, we had 8 M's
and
uh yeah, these are very different
parameters
what we used to have. I'm going to try
these
just to see that is what happens.
We'll go from there.
Instant ns.
Instantly nanss. Okay.
if heavy ball, right?
Oh, well, this is running freaking Atom
for some dumb reason.
Let's not do that. That's Let's run a
real optimizer here.
That looks a lot better, right? Looks
like what it was before.
Is my chat broken?
Yeah, there we go. So, that's what we'd
expect, right? 27 seconds solve
3.7 mills per second.
So from here
let's see if we cannot figure out
I just run the same sort of policy out
of the box.
I'm actually kind of curious how much
this is like what happens if I just do
this.
So, I can double the model size here
and still get something pretty
reasonable.
Not much slower either.
No.
Okay.
But what happens if I do like this on
layers two,
you still get something that's very
stable, right?
What this looks like. Make sure this is
actually getting used
default policy.
Ah, okay. It's using this one,
but still it's applying it, right?
Uh, you know, one thing we can do to
check this,
like if I change this from an LSTM to a
a GRU,
it also screw things up.
Yeah, let's just copy this whole bloody
thing.
Okay.
Been pawned by a grill.
Okay. It's literally the same, isn't it?
I HH
I see weight ih and I see weight hh. So
I think you can literally just do the
same thing. No.
X
and
expected.
Yeah. So, it's only one state is the
thing.
Just return like this.
It's a tpple.
Um, does it need to be a tpple or can I
just have it return
zoom in row?
Gradually implementing puffer into
autonomous marine vehicle. Cool.
I am working on making puffer very fast.
It takes some work. Next version is a
lot of work.
soon as it's done. Man, I'm working as
fast as I can.
I'm doing the best I can here. It's just
like
I have to keep myself in the productive
regime, so to speak.
Okay. I mean, that just immediately does
almost as well, right?
what is prerequisite to start RL?
Uh that would be ML and after linear
algebra like that's math. You missed the
whole programming portion, right?
Like the work I do is 85% engineering,
strong programming background, which is
not really a matter of coursework. It's
more a matter of having experience
building stuff without making a mess.
Let me link you my guide. Have you read
my guide articles?
I wrote them for exactly this reason
because it's the most common question I
get asked.
So, if you look here, X has this
articles tab
and there's my RL guide. And then if
you're asking that question, you should
probably also read the uh programming
and ML guide. It's my highest rated
piece of content.
I mean this kind of does say that no
matter what you do, you can kind of do
pretty well on this quickly, right?
And like what if I just stack another
layer on it?
This was the one thing I was worried
about, right, was this architecture
being um we're having major problems.
We'll see. I think I can still get stuff
out of it, though.
That's not ideal.
Hang on.
I did miss that this had the expansion
factor is two. So this is actually
closer to um
maybe we should just go try to
understand what the heck the difference
is here.
We go look at grew
versus mining grew.
We can just easily look at the weight
shapes, right?
Uh, okay. Well, I was not expecting that
size.
Three gates.
Oh, it does have three gates.
going to be the minimum size.
Well, where the hell the rest of the uh
the weights come from then,
huh?
No, it's not.
A
Oh, cuz it's that times two.
Interesting.
But wait, then you would expect
be 256
* 128 * 2, right? It would be 65k
per
Yeah. So, this thing completely like
eliminates
all the capacity from this thing now.
So presumably you at least have to
parameter match it.
uses
33%. Is that correct?
Yeah, cuz it's one six uh one/3
cuz it's six gates versus two.
So, I mean, then there's no reason to
expect this thing to remotely
work out of the box,
right?
So, then what we'd have to do
147k.
So, if I'm correct,
this only has two.
So, you should be able to stack four
layers of this crap. No.
Yeah,
it's almost the exact same number. Is it
146.8?
Yeah, it's almost the exact same number
of parameters.
I mean, we'll do that to start.
Stacking four deep is also kind of nutty
though
just click the most likely starting
point here. And what we'll do,
we'll figure out why the hell the
dynamics are like this.
Okay, this actually does get us to
something reasonable here, right?
So that's like there's hope.
There's hope for that.
You're doing HPO. I'm not doing HO in
real time.
I'm kind of doing the opposite.
I have a set of hypers that works very
well for breakout. I've tested that it's
relatively stable across a range of
different things. And I'm just seeing if
there are any like things about Mingru
that make it particularly weird.
we get this. This is where we got this
from. So this the same
This doesn't get any sort of special in
it
thing.
Well, I was just wondering if Mamba had
done like some um
any sort of like normalization after the
scan op. I'm just wondering if there's
anything numerically scary with the scan
op basically
Yeah. So they have
RMS norm.
I just want to see if they've done
something with it.
This code is actually quite good, but
this is not the officially released one.
This is Lucid Rance.
Okay, here it is. So,
dim.
Yeah. So you see this
they have
RMS norm
equals min group plus
X.
Let's just skip connect.
Doesn't look like a big massive like
duh, you just need a skip connect,
right? 546. And then we'll let it run
again.
But then there's also the
FF norm.
It does better without the the skip
connect. Okay.
what is about 15%.
And I definitely have um I have an
architecture here that we need to figure
out.
So basically I need to figure out if
Mingru is going to be a acceptable
replacement for LSTM cuz I can optimize
the crap out of this thing. Um, but
ultimately like the it has to be
powerful enough on its own.
Oh, holy hell. Yeah, there's the RMS
norm does a ton for this. That's
interesting,
horizon. Yeah. Well, that's what I want
to test because it's kind of a weirdly
formulated recurrent net.
Oh yeah, Jess. It's one of those like
it's one of those expressions that just
doesn't make any bloody sense if you
think about it.
so yeah, I mean, Kyouung, this is the uh
the key thing honestly at the moment for
us is if we can figure out
if we can come up with a uh a parallel
RNN, which this is, that like matches or
exceeds
um LSTM PF,
then we're kind of golden.
And like it's not going to be super fast
in the torch version, uh, at least up
front, but I can make this very Fast.
Like I've rewritten a good chunk of
Torch at this point.
And this can be done
can be done quickly enough, I believe.
How about getting rid of mean and search
center? Um,
don't you need those though?
Yo, Kyouong, don't you need those? Cuz
you still sample that distribution,
don't you?
So deep into 2048.
Yeah. Well, I appreciate it. That's
going to be an awesome end.
I've been dealing with like absolute
hell as well from um like all the
low-level stuff I was dealing with. I
had to track down numerical bugs that
were on the order of like 1 e minus 6
that were indistinguishable from just
like floating point or even double
precision calc errors.
I use whatever is specified in the
default. Well, how do you sample
like when you select new when you're
generating new candidates? Like how are
you generating those candidates without
a search distribution?
Yeah, I think we can get rid of those
then, Kung. I think it's better to just
use the uh the specified default.
Yeah, cuz then you're actually you
guarantee that you start off with a very
strong run or like you start off with
your le like your best run. Um,
yeah, I think that's fine.
And then what we'll just do, right, is
we'll start with like our default config
and then all sweeps will just be off of
that and that'll be the benchmark.
That'll be solid.
That sounds good to me.
That makes sense. And then I can just go
ahead and run that. Oh yeah. Have you
tried So have you done 2048 sweeps with
the multi sweep or just with the Neptune
back end? That's the one other thing I'd
want to know
cuz like I want to basically run a sweep
to see if I can get
um some permutation of mining to be on
par.
single box.
Okay.
Well, I have to test that stuff. Yeah,
you've done more than enough though
already. Thank you.
So the language models are stupid.
Yay.
That's super funny.
Left, right, up, down. You can get 28.
You can literally beat the original game
with this.
Funny.
Should write a uh you should write up a
post on this.
Yeah, it's very difficult with something
like 2048 to figure out like over what
sub like what of that horizon. It's like
a very cyclical game, right? So, I don't
know over what actual length of time
you're you need to strategize or
whatnot. But I mean, this is still like
super solid.
I mean, just the fact that the curve is
what it is, like the learn curve, that
on its own is enough to sort of
demonstrate it as a benchmark.
Yeah. So, this is kind of the cool
thing, Chang. Um, if we get this net to
work, this net is fast with longer
horizons. So, it doesn't have the same
like uh batching restrictions that the
other net has, which is the awesome bit
about it. The not so awesome bit about
it is it's an utter pain in the ass uh
to implement fast, but I already did
that part, but we have experiments that
need to be done.
So, the cool thing about this model as
well is it's um it's a linear
recurrence.
So, you don't need to have uh annoying
context
on uh the rollouts.
I see. So the way that you want to do
this,
Okay, so one layer of mining
not so good.
Did you do better by making the network
a little better? Yeah.
But not by a lot.
And then we can do
expansion factor. Go back to one
num layer. Go to three.
And if I go to um what happens if I just
make it really deep?
How is this only 213k
grams? That doesn't make Oh, no. That
makes sense.
As Kyouung and Spencer have both learned
enough that it is time for them to take
their own mentees.
You know, this is kind of exciting
because this is one of the very few
instances I've seen where I can just
increase the net size and not [ __ ]
things up.
Can I do like something ridiculous?
Can I make a 12 layer network that
actually works in RL?
That might have been a little bit much
full of layer.
Oh,
hang on.
Hey guys,
I got a 12 layer network to train in RL.
This is so funny to me because it's like
like dude, what are you talking about?
Everybody trains 12 layer networks.
Yeah, well we don't do it in RL. Okay.
If the network does even if it doesn't
do better, if it does this well, like
this is a usable architecture. This is
solid enough.
That standard puffer algo. Yeah, it is.
It's just the new architecture, man.
This is now parameter matched with the
original. But let's see.
We can train stuff.
All the networks I'm seeing in paper
code are way bigger than puff or way
bigger for RL.
Well, that's okay. Okay, nobody knows
what the [ __ ] they're doing in this
field
smarter net because I have the look at
training curve.
yeah, that is chef's kiss for a training
curve.
Yeah, for RL but off Paul.
Just don't I I don't know. I've done
enough of my own research on this stuff
to know that it's just I can ignore the
[ __ ] out of all that. FBR, welcome.
No, my 12 layers wasn't running at 3
mil, but like I can get it to run at 3
mil.
This is like a good
good setup. Um,
CTS.
No, I do not know any test from CTS.
Oh yeah, Kyouong has been messing with
uh 2048. It's the same Yanick, right?
Wait, is that this is the same Yanick,
right?
Cuz if so, man, this ENV ended up being
really really good for research.
I swear if you do lowle game dev, you
just help advance RL as a field.
I gota get I got to get a couple sets in
and I got to kill a couple flies. Give
me a minute.
Like fly season or something. I mean
nuts.
The big dumb ones that just let you kill
them as well.
No puffer university.
Puffer apprenticeship however is
available.
Okay, different Yanick.
Could have been this Yanick. See, just
build some silly low-level games and you
turn out doing a damn good thing for
research now and again.
Spicy 6 million SPS.
Jesus
with 16ks though.
At least it's fast.
I'd like to use the new one.
3.7 mil perrams. Woof.
I'm honestly kind of surprised then uh
that it got to a network that big. Man,
that's bigger than neural MMO 3.
6.7 billion steps.
Yes.
Now, let's see if this thing works first
and then we can compare this to uh new
decent mining.
You swept the network size and it just
got to be 3.7 mil per
No, it built in is fine, Kung.
It's fine to have it built in.
Just increasing Does it act did you know
that the actual network capacity helps
Kung? Like it does better with bigger
networks if you run for the same amount
of time.
It helps. H
interesting.
Interesting.
No, Breakout is not like Tetris is not
like this either though. Really? How's
Tetris?
actually kind of surprised to be honest
if it's harder than Tetris. like that's
kind of odd to me
and you know um
react it's a more reactive game. Yeah,
but like there's still some amount of
planning
and how are you encoding the uh the
blocks? I am somewhat concerned that
maybe it's just like it can't see the
values on the blocks correctly or like
the way it's getting encoded. Maybe like
it just has to learn new features every
time it gets to uh a new block size or
some weird thing.
There is definitely some strategy though
in Tetris with like you know how you
respond to bad pieces which you will get
over the over the course of a game and
like you know okay if I mess this thing
up a little now I'll be able to recover
it later by doing this
for Tetris there's like still some
stuff I think Tetris though the obs are
good right like the obs are pretty
obvious I'm just not sure with is 2048
Eight. Is do you know that the OB
structure is reasonable? Because like
it's actually not clear to me initially
what the best way to encode that is
because if you just like one hot the
tiles probably has to learn new
features.
H yeah I don't actually know the best
way to encode the uh the obs.
Yeah. 100 tick horizon. Do you know for
sure that you need to plan longer than
100 ticks though in 2048
one hunt
I think that the same thing with 2048
could be happening with neural MMO where
we have like suboptimal obscenings
How high is this uh this version
supposed to get? Kyouong, do you
remember?
Controls, what are you doing? FBR, what
are you doing? Oh, lots of problems. Uh,
some problems where large nets just
don't train. Yeah, that's a thing.
That is a thing. And you have to retune
learning rates and stuff as well.
But that is just generally a a thing
that happens in RL.
I wanted to find that. Where is the
rant?
Okay, 1909.
That's not a good score is the problem,
but we'll use it as a baseline anyways.
Sometimes reaches HK 8K. Well, that's
fiddly.
It's not a good thing for it to be that
The heck happened here?
Couldn't be 1.6 mil.
Yo. Um, what's going on with this
policy?
Neural net basically simulates all
possible configurations of all agents.
No, that is not true.
It simulates a bunch of rollouts. Yeah,
Monte Carlo style in a sense.
And then it upweights actions that led
to good rewards and it downweights
actions that did not lead to good
rewards.
It's not always true that the more
agents you put in, the faster it solves.
There's a learning signal to hardware to
um what is it? Learning signal to
uh yeah, hardware to like there's a
bunch of trade-offs with that.
Yeah. So, this tank's SPS
by a lot.
Um, but we're basically assuming here
that
uh I mean, I definitely can get this to
run way faster, right?
Yeah. So if this does well then this is
a very good sign. And basically if this
does well it means we can sweep more
stuff.
Yeah. So, I think when you have that PR,
Kyouong, um I'm going to want to have
I'm going to want that PR and I'm going
to also want to merge it into 40 as
well. Um and then what we're going to do
is we're going to try the Mingru sweep
over everything,
Okay, so this actually potentially saves
quite a bit.
Uh, unfortunately, it also means I just
have to launch these experiments, then
go back to mining. Uh, back to the CUDA
mines. Drives me nuts.
Let me think what we can do.
We wanted to figure out breakout in the
meantime, right?
Well, we'll see whether this does as
well, but at least this is like a viable
model so far.
Kind of funny though, you really need
the RMS norm.
I wonder why you need the RMS form.
That's kind of weird, isn't it?
not specific benchmark.
I don't know what you're on about.
Come to think of it, this is not even
that bad, right? Because like
normally uh you do
two matrix multiplications per layer for
uh like an LSTM cell.
And now this is only this is four matrix
multiplications
or no it's six. Okay. It's still some
overhead and launches but
we can still make it faster
Okay, Kyouong. This is definitely
better. It's gotten the same score in
half the number of steps
parameter matched,
which I suppose is expected.
max perf on that. Oh yeah, this can get
like the 64k
that uh Kyouong has, but not with this
version of it.
Well, this beats uh this gets the 2048
here
If this actually this architecture ends
up working and making it into puffer 4,
I got to write an article like basically
saying what imbecile like cuz the mining
group paper did not get published. It
got rejected from publishing with like
one of the stupidest [ __ ] uh open
review threads I've ever seen.
There's no paddle somehow.
Somehow there is no paddle.
Well, that will explain it.
Uh, I think that if you just if you just
llm generate a review that clearly
demonstrates you didn't read the paper,
you should be banned from reviewing, uh,
banned from submitting for a decent
chunk of time. and your university
should be informed and you should at
least get a suspension
at the very least
cuz you're just sabotaging people's
work.
And if you do that at a company, you
should probably just be [ __ ] fired.
But right now, there's zero
repercussions because apparently it's
not nice to punish people for being
shipbags.
I had this happen with RLC, right, where
they wouldn't even like a guy like wrote
a false review about my paper because he
just gpted it and like they wouldn't
even take any action.
So much easier to just brush things
under the rug.
Yeah. I don't know. Sometimes I wish I
could just be more zen about everything
and just like calmly go through and do
all my work and like, you know, build
all the crazy things I build, but I just
am not. Like I'm not built that way,
man. Like stuff just pisses me off so
much.
I bet you this init function is not
getting called.
Oh, I'm going to be mad
if it's
Oh, it's supposed to get set right
there.
See reset.
How can they not? Dude, it's like it's
so easy. It's the easiest thing ever for
them to do nothing.
I mean, people are just like conflict
conflict averse to the utterly stupidest
degree.
How does this get um
the paddle width assigned?
Oh, well, it is actually broken.
That's interesting.
I guess something got merged without
realizing.
How the hell is it working in Python,
then?
We'll have to figure that out. I think I
know what happened though. Stupid merge.
Give me a few minutes. I got to use a
restroom. Got to do a couple sets. We'll
fix this. We'll stop being in complete
and utter hell.
And we will continue on. Yes. Um and uh
it looks like the mining crew is doing
decently as well. So that's cool. I'll
be back.
All right.
Go figure out why C++ does not like
paddle.
The editor. My guy. You think there's an
editor?
Cool. Let me fix um the mystery of the
disappearing paddle and then I can give
you a review today if you want.
Easiest training program ever. It's just
very simple. You do one set and then
every time you do a set, you do another
set.
This is totally invalid, isn't it? Where
the [ __ ] did this get introduced?
find the victim.
I mean, it very well might just be me
screwing up. Yeah. So, I mean, this is
totally [ __ ] broken here.
If I let some AI [ __ ] get past me, like
kind of on me unless it was smuggled
into something stupid.
Oh, did I do it?
If I did it, then I'm an imbecile.
Very good, sir.
Very good.
I don't know how I haven't seen that in
three months.
Paddle is there. Rio, uh, when you run
it from Python, it's fine. Kyouong,
it was an error in the way that I
initialized it in the C file as well as
in my C back end.
The GPT reviewer would catch this. Now,
a GPT reviewer would [ __ ] it up, man.
would introduce it most likely.
Or it would catch that and it would
catch 10 other things that don't
actually exist, making it worthless.
Oh yeah, Kyouong Miningru gets uh 2500
compared to like 1,700 for um
whatever the the default was. So I think
that Mingru is actually going to work.
M grew
and then it's not going to be fast in
torch but it'll be fast in um
well it can be fast in torch to be fair.
I just have to expose my kernels.
Suffice to say it will be fast.
Pardon for missing that. I've been in a
uh a pretty deep dev hole lately.
The vast majority of my time goes into
making puffer liib what it is and I
occasionally miss um
new things.
Are you free later today to discuss
after uh I finish this work block.
I have to learn more about the project
because that's like a very rushed thing
if it's of that level of complexity.
It depends on um well we'll discuss
soon.
Are you in a US time zone?
four or six.
All right, I sent back. Should be I'm
free four or six Eastern. So, uh one or
three
Hang on. Let me go get my make my
Discord update work so I can uh go check
the guy has availability
Yeah,
I'm going to have to get details on
that. That's a very rush job. Like, we
can do it, but we'd have to drop a lot
of stuff. Just FYI. Like, there will be
an upcharge for that. But it looks like
something that's in our wheelhouse.
Yep.
Okay, sounds good. We will chat soon.
Let me set myself an alarm for that.
I'm going to see if I can get my other
guy in as well.
So, can't we just do
Eval
If I die only break
Oh,
Yeah. Yeah, dummy. I forgot about this.
Okay, this is fine.
Psych major trying to get into RL and
Puffer. Recommend CS231N
is a prerec. Can I speedrun Carpathy and
jump? Dive right in. Do you know how to
program?
That's the key thing.
And if you're asking if you can speedrun
Carpathy, um CS231N is his course. Like
he lectures it. He made the course. Him
and Justin.
The old videos that he has are still
good.
Some X with Python scripts game modding
his YouTube series. Which YouTube
series? Because he like he he does the
lectures for CS231 and they're on
YouTube as well.
The hardest thing for you is not going
to be anything to do with RL. The
hardest thing for you is just going to
be core programming.
I have a couple guides. This will give
you like general advice, but like the
hardest thing is just learning core
programming,
honestly.
Like start here.
This will at least prevent you from
wasting your time doing dumb things like
going to bad resources. This will give
you like you should probably read this
if you're going to be learning a bunch
of stuff really quick like read this
article once every couple weeks to
ground yourself. It's a pretty short
read at least the programming section of
it. Um, you basically need to learn core
programming and then core ML stuff.
And Carpathy has some really great
content on that, but like it's it's not
going to be super friendly to a newbie,
right? Like
uh what did he do? Like even GPT2,
you know, like something like this is a
really good project to look at.
Wait, where is it?
I thought he did. Uh, where was his P1?
No, not this one.
Nano GPT.
Where was this like GPT2 with C
Z C thing?
I haven't looked at this one yet. He has
several. Yeah. No, not this.
Damn it, Carpathy.
He has some like good um like lowlevel
stuff though. lm.c Thank you
here.
This is like really good stuff.
I'm going to be using this as a
reference as well for a decent amount of
things,
but it's not going to be super newbie
friendly, right? It's clean, but it's
not going to be super newbie friendly. I
also don't know why he did this in C++.
It's kind of gross.
Zero to hero. I have not done that. You
can try it though. He generally does
make good educational content. So
Okay, cool. So this is now um breakout
training with the CAPI. not doing
particularly well,
but it does exist.
We have to go match the architecture
to the Python one and do a bunch of
other stuff.
And this performance is awful, but hey,
at least it exists now.
What's the faster alternative you're
thinking of? The same thing, but
actually a bigger network that runs
faster.
It's going to be 10 million steps per
second. For Puffer 4, I'm not releasing
Puffer 4 below 10 million steps per
second.
If you're still here, I will review uh
your N.
Perfect.
Let's go look at your N.
Unable to What the heck happened?
enabled and select next GitHub token
from pool.
It's annoying. Start with the puffer.
other way. It helps out a lot.
Is this guy Is this like an automated PR
guy? Like this guy's like opened several
really really stupid PRs for no reason.
Like why the hell would you do this?
Okay. Multi- aent with different
strategies trying to win at artillery.
See?
So, we've got
1024 m
has
whole bunch of params.
Okay.
Standard network
looks like tuned hypers.
Uh, no. This is jank.
Yo, Kin, what is this supposed to be?
You have 1024 M's. Oh, no, never mind.
No, this works. Yeah, this works. I
forgot. You have so few M's. This is
actually fine. Okay.
Very weird. These are still very weird
parameters to have, but okay.
The RNG better not be in here. Okay. The
RNG is not a sweep parameter. You've
avoided
accusations sweeping RNG.
Um,
okay.
We got our Alex here.
This two agent it looks like.
you're allocating one for float? Wait,
is this multi- aent? Why is allocate
have
you've got two for actions and only one
for float? Oh, quasi.
What's quasi multi-agent mean?
I guess we'll find out.
I have one model multi-discreet.
Huh?
Oh, wait. The actions are it's shooting
both of them.
But then what's the reward?
Because if it's one model optimizing one
goal, is the goal that like they both
hit each other?
You even put a linear LSTM in here.
Cool.
You're going to come to me next week
with a Palunteer contract or something.
Oh yeah.
Wait. Move forward with what though?
Okay.
Fox space
discrete.
Yeah. So, this is considered a single
agent amp then, man. It's not quasi
multi- aent. This is just considered
single agent. This is so for reference
this is by definition if you use the
same policy jointly to compute the
actions it is single agent.
If you use the same set of weights
applied independently then it's multi-
aent. The thing that matters is whether
the computation of actions is joint.
Yeah. So like even if you have like
let's say that you have a tank, okay,
and like the tank can move and the tank
can like steer or like the tank can
fire. If one if you have a policy that
controls the firing independently from a
policy that controls the steering, that
is a multi- aent environment. That is
the same thing as if I release a co-op
game on Steam in which like you have two
players, one of whom is responsible for
firing and the other is responsible for
moving. That is a multi- aent
environment.
And other people will disagree with me,
but they're wrong. This is the most
useful definition.
Standard binds. The net
logs.
You missed Perf as a metric.
It'd be nice to add Perf, but this Okay.
Hey, Peru
01 normalize because otherwise convert
it makes it hard for me to put your
stuff on um like constellation.
So because for constellation we have
everything normed
artillery.
I did.
Okay, now we look at the actual code now
that I've nitpicked
things that don't actually matter.
Okay. Okay. So, it's an iterated action
space in the sense that you can like
Yeah, this is chill
tried puffer drive with my native
10% game
but saturates GPU. I was actually
looking at your threading Peru. It's
going to get it's going to get
integrated pretty soon.
What do you mean saturates GPU fast
there?
Oh, it's like this. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Uh, Peru, actually, I have
something for you to look into. Uh, give
me one minute, Convert, to just address
this and then we will go back to review.
My bad. Um, so
Yeah. So, here, let me show you
something because I actually am I'm
going to need your multi-threading soon,
but I'm going to integrate it, I think,
in a way that's compatible with both
pure CPP and Python. Uh, and I really
the one thing I really didn't like about
your PR was the fact that you had to add
an extra parameter to all the M's. Like,
that's you can't just add stuff to the
signatures like that. That's got to be
like a a global param or something. We
got to figure that out.
Okay. Yeah, right here. So, in C++
I have uh pinned memory here used and I
have timed this. This cuts down uh CPU
toGPU overhead by a factor of two.
So doing something like this and this is
really obnoxious to do with
multipprocessing because of shared
memory because it's really annoying to
get like shared plus pinned. I could
never figure that figure that out. But I
think with threading this works.
So I think with threading uh the
threadbased backend we can have the uh
the environments manage their memory
like this.
And it doesn't have to be through torch
either. Like it can just be numpy array
backed or whatever probably. Um but we
can have that be pinned memory. And then
when you do
this evaluate step, it'll be the same in
Python and CPP.
Um but in this evaluate step,
this op here, where is it? Yeah, this op
here gets twice as fast. And this is the
bottleneck op.
But I think this is the key thing. Um,
yeah, this is like the key key thing
right now
because I checked it out and I think
actually we're probably going to want to
still have some GPU M, but it's nowhere
near as clear-cut. Like I don't think
it's going to be realistic that we just
make all our M's also work on GPU and to
be fast. I think that even if I make all
our M's work on GPU, they're not going
to be fast on GPU because we're just
doing arbitrary branching and saying
screw it, a GPU is a CPU, right?
A class puffer.
Yeah,
I actually don't know a good way to do
it off the top of my head with the
number of threads like that. I think
probably
Yeah, probably endbinding should manage
that, right? like endbinding should
probably manage maximum threads for you.
But then I also I hate the fact that we
have endbinding right now because I
don't want the C++ I don't want the C
threading logic mixed up with the Python
binds because I need to use that C logic
for making M's. I actually need to make
that a standalone so I can call into it
um from the C++ backend without having
to go through the Python binds. Right?
So, uh, long story short though, you are
absolutely 100% for sure I'm going to be
using um a like thread-based back end
for the C++. So, your work is getting
incorporated in the next update. And
thank you very much for it.
It's just a little bit more complicated
as to how.
And now I will convert his review.
Where's your review?
Right.
GPUms will work. Yeah. Yo, Peru, do you
have any idea if I were to just like run
neural MMO, just like run the CC code as
CUDA code, do you have any idea how fast
it would be if I basically just said
screw it? I know GPUs aren't designed
for this, but we're doing it anyways.
Lauren will look at puffer drive.
A lot of people are using puffer drive.
Works without branches.
No, no, it's tons of branches. Peru.
That's the thing. It's arbitrary. It's
like game code, right? Arbitrary
branching logic.
If you just run it on GPU and say, "I'm
running 4,000 copies of this environment
in parallel, but with a bunch of
branching, instead of having a CPU core
running all 4,000 copies, right?
That will speed up."
But like if it's 10x faster, it's still
good, right? even if it's the same speed
because there's no host device transfer.
The only thing that's worse is if it
like
if it like if it runs way slower than on
a CPU core, then it's really bad. You
know, I think honestly we're going to
just end up doing um host device
transfer in pinned memory and we're
probably going to end up buffering the
transfers and call it a day and then we
should be able to get what's PCIe is it
like 32 gigs?
I think we'll just get 32 gigs of
bandwidth transfer and we'll call it a
day. We'll be good.
Okay, now I really got to like not uh
No, I'm being disrespectful to Kvert
here. So, let's let me get his review
done.
Yeah, you're free to do that, Peru.
Like, that's Go ahead. It's all in the
40 branch.
Yeah, man. cuz yeah, I got to get a
review done because I've got uh when do
when was this meeting?
Oh, I've got time. I got an hour and a
half. Cool. Uh
okay, we got a couple basic trucks.
These are fine.
OBS, actions, rewards, terms. Yep, this
Fine.
I don't know what this eye is.
[ __ ]
Okay,
What's the uh the obs like max tick
say
projectile time?
What's max tick?
Yeah, you just want to make sure your
obs don't explode is the thing.
Because like if it's goes for 10,000
steps
or longer like that can be bad. So you
want to it's not like if your obs goes
to two your network immediately diverges
but if you like have rare cases where
you get 100 in the obs or something
that's really bad.
And yes technically you can do stuff at
the architecture level but we generally
just like cut the problem from the start
with this
75 steps. Okay. If it's 75 then it's
fine.
random start.
Okay, so it just randomly sets.
Wait, penal.
Oh, it's supposed to be penalty, but
it's penal.
No, it is penalty nen.
I do not have dyslexia, but whatever the
hell this has gave me.
It It looks like pen. Why does that look
like penalty is misspelled to me? Like
with the N on the end. That's so weird.
It looks fine if I highlight it like
this to me, but with the N on the end,
it's like it screws up something.
Okay.
Uh
yeah,
spy. This is called a [ __ ] code
review.
If I'm man, I'm in damn better shape
than you are.
I'll be in better shape shape than you
young at 20 when I'm 30.
It's all right. We'll cure aging at some
point soon anyways, right?
All right. What we got? Al parabola
closest.
Uh, what's this?
Wait, is this literally are you
rewarding them for being close to the
perfect like the trajectory you want or
something? Convert.
They only get reward when they shoot.
Okay. So, wait then. What is this for?
I guess we'll see.
Spy is funny cuz he's like always here
trolling, but he's like not a very
advanced troll.
We need to like upgrade the troll model
software.
There's like GPT2 of trolling.
Okay. Grab score.
What's this do?
Oh, wait. They get reward then they
shoot. Oh, yo, Kvert, do they get reward
based on how close their shot? Like how
close their angle is when they're
shooting to um
like it calculates where the bullet is
going to go or whatever and it
calculates how close they are to that
trajectory.
Is this like a super aggressively shaped
reward?
They only get reward but they don't get
reward for hitting the target, right?
It's not just like you get rewarded for
hitting the target. You're getting
rewarded for some other stuff, right?
cuz you're trying to get like the
different trajectories.
Okay,
then like yes, obviously this will work
if you're going to shape it like this.
I mean you take a lot of difficulty out
of the problem but sure.
Biggest criticism so far is that the
name is [ __ ] Artillery my guy. So
much easier.
right. There's a difference between
trolling and just being a dick in my
chat, so stop it, man.
I don't like having things that change
the behavior with the renderer are not
on, man.
Especially when it's like this is
changing terminals behavior.
Yeah, it's just because you've done the
rewards a little bit weird.
I think I'd get arrested cuz you're
probably like 12. Um
Okay.
Yeah, it's kind of just a weird reward
setup, frankly.
And that's like causing other weirdness.
I see why you've done the things and
nothing's like egregiously terrible.
Cool. And where's the where's the end
here? You sent me the end at some point
in the Discord, right?
No, no. Like where you sent there's an
image, right?
I remember seeing an image of this
recently.
Uh, you forget how stupid people are at
that age. I for one remember being
incredibly stupid.
Hell, I remember being incredibly stupid
for several years after that as well. I
was still incredibly stupid even when I
was starting to publish research. Man,
is what it is. That's why I'm lenient.
Yeah. I mean, so Kin, you made it a
really freaking easy problem with the
way that you did the rewards, right?
Yeah. I mean, like the way that you
would do this, right, is it would be
like you give reward for hitting the
target and then there's probably would
be like another reward for being as low
trajectory as possible versus like a
reward for being as high trajectory as
possible. Um,
it would be something like that.
So, I mean, this is a really easy
environment the way it's written. But if
you want it to be like this, that's
fine. Like, just clean up the couple
small things, fix like change the name
of it to something reasonable, and we
can merge this.
Maybe tweak the background colors and
stuff a little.
Like cuz basically, man, this is like a
this is like a few problem at this
point. You basically just has to like
turn to angle and fire and it
immediately gets the reward.
So like the learning problem, so most of
the environments that we have, the
learning problem is at least as complex
as it looks. This environment, I think
that the learning problem is way simpler
than this looks.
How close they are.
Yeah. I mean, exactly though, right?
It's I guess it's funny that you like
even draw the parabola for them. It's
not as bad given that you draw the
parabola like that cuz like a person can
see this as well.
They learn. Yeah. They don't really have
to discover hitting anything. Yeah.
Cuz otherwise like the only really
challenge in here would be that it's
kind of delayed and then you have this
like funny multid-discreet two
components thing going on.
If you want it to be like this though,
it's fine. And it's an environment.
Just like fix the couple things and
we'll merge it.
I mean, this would just be considered
like extreme reward engineering
for 2.0. I mean, I think you can easily
solve this problem just based on like
reward for hit the target and like, you
know, make it a little larger or smaller
depending on if you want it to be uh lob
versus straight shot.
I mean, unless you have the frame rate
cranked to something stupid, right?
Like, yeah, you might want frame like
some frame skip on it because otherwise
if it's takes two seconds for the bullet
to hit, then it's like uh it that could
be like 60 delay like a 60step delay in
credit assignment, which is kind of
jank.
But otherwise, it's pretty solid.
Well, I mean, presumably you'll still
want to like build stuff to improve
skill set, right?
This is the best place to be for uh
pool RL.
Okay,
I'm use the restroom real quick. I'm
going to get a couple of sets in
Gvert, was it you or Plasma that uh was
into calisthenics for both?
There's plasma. Then the other guy
might have been captain
used to have 120 years ago. It's 1/5 of
yours. Home gym is good. The stuff I use
in here most of the time these days,
honestly, I use my bench
and I use my cables more than anything.
I mean, if you have a a rack, a rack
counts as a bench, right? Honestly, just
racking cables gets you a lot. Like, um,
I think uh the other guys make this as
well.
Something like this. The There's the
other company that makes these that's
getting pretty good. What's the other
one?
Uh, I forget. There's like one other
company that's like almost this quality
as well.
I have one of these in uh in Florida
where I don't have space for a full gem.
These are a pain in the ass to assemble
though, be warned.
Build in.
Uh, I mean like a onecar garage is
basically the amount of space you
typically will want for like a minimum
setup.
Okay, let's figure out what's going on
then with um with our models.
Did we not do multiple layer?
Multi-layered.
I didn't do multi-layered.
Oh, oops.
We have to add multilayer in here.
Okay,
we can do that.
push back
and try it
the expansion factor.
Fine.
Uh
correct.
Cool.
And this one
And we'll just have to figure out how to
get a um a multi-layered version of this
running.
Oh, is it just is it this simple?
It is.
and just index it like this. Probably
not, right?
Have you heard of the flashlight
library? No.
C++ native ML library.
Why is everything always C++, man? I
don't want more C++. I want to remove
all C++.
Give me some damn C.
Why the hell don't we have like just a
simple C tensor library?
You literally do it in 2K lines.
be seek hidden.
Okay.
Uh
Nice. We already got to
here.
Thank you. Helpful comment from me from
the past.
Nice.
We got to train.
Now for train,
we do the exact same thing,
right? Let's
Heck is wrong with this? Then there's no
layers.
Should be fine,
I would think.
That's um
Um,
did X lock?
Oh, they messed with the XUI a whole
bunch.
Okay. So, this takes the speed down as
expected.
Um,
and this is Adam. So, we're not
expecting very much, right, with muan
params.
So yeah, the next thing would be to
figure out
who won and a few other bits.
And we're going to experiment with Muan
just a minute.
Let me get a couple quick sets in
though.
We are making some good progress today.
Pain in the ass, but we're making
progress.
so
move on time.
Welcome.
I don't know what kind of question that
is, but welcome.
Well, looks like Muan works to me,
right?
actually just did better than the heavy
ball implementation. So
Yeah, this is what I was worried about.
Is it not in C++?
Damn it. Did they literally just do it
in Python?
Nerds.
The code is always terrible.
Is this the entire thing? At least
at least the whole thing is in this
file.
Not that long.
Use anything fancy.
Think so.
Oh, I should just go look at the atom,
shouldn't I?
I need to find their actual Atom
implementation, don't I?
Hello. What are you doing today? Hello,
Liberty. Welcome. Uh I'm actually
leaving in just a couple of minutes. But
today what I've done is um I have gotten
the breakout thing fixed. I have uh made
a small architectural change to mining
that makes it actually learn properly.
I've added multilayer support to Mingru.
Um
reviewed one NPR and done a couple other
things. And I've got a business meeting
to go to in a few minutes.
was it a small error? Um
yeah, it turned out that uh there was a
bug not in the torch C++ but there was a
bug in the end of initialization where
it literally was not creating the
paddle. So there was no way to hit the
ball because there was no paddle. I
rendered it and it was like, "What the
hell? There's no paddle.
and we've integrated Muon.
Not really, it's Adam W renamed, but uh
that's going to be the next task is we
need to have an actual Muan
implementation that works.
It actually might be torch optiman
because I have the name space.
undefined symbol. Yeah. Okay. So this
does not exist
good though.
Well, I got to get to my meeting
anyways.
So um we will continue this either later
tonight or tomorrow.
I've honestly I've been trying to pace
myself lately because this stuff has
just been getting me really burnt out.
So maybe tomorrow we will see. Um
anyways, thank you for tuning in folks.
My work is all free and open source. At
least all the code bases are. Um if
you're interested, puffer.ai for all the
things. I'll fix this star macro thing
tomorrow, but star the puffer. Feed the
puffer star. He likes stars. Helps out a
lot. Uh Discord if you want to get
involved with dev. And other than that,
you can follow me on X educational
contents on the articles tab. More
things there as well.